Now let's talk through the choices I've given you. yes, the operating system is a
resource manager. It is the boss in control of the hardware resources. So that's
a functionality that you do expect from
the operating system. Yes, the operating system -
Is the entity that provides a consistent
interface to the hardware resource. Remember earlier lecture
on obstructions, I mentioned that operating system is
a level in the obstruction hierarchy sitting between the
application and the processor and the other resources
and so in this sense, the operating system should
be the entity that provides a consistent interface
to the hardware resources such as CPU, memory, and
io devices. So yes, the second choice is
a good one in terms of functionality, that you
would expect from an operating system. The
third choice says the operating systems schedules applications
on the CPU. This also seems like a
think that the operating system should do because
there could be multiple applications that require
these resources and therefore their has to be
an arbitor that is going to provide a
way of scheduling. Those requests on the hardware
devices and therefore yes. The operating system
is an entity that schedules applications on
top of the CPU. The last choice
says the operating system stores personal information
such as credit card numbers, social security
number and email addresses. Now this looks
like something that you wouldn't have want
the operating system to do. And these are,
these are personal information and you would
not want the operating system to store such
information, and therefore this is not a
functionality that you expect of the operating system.
So the first three choices are the right choices. The operating system is not an
entity that should be storing your personal information
such as credit card numbers and so on.